get used to this
the coming days will see strikes on the
trains at Royal Mail and in the NHS
Royal College of Nursing members are due
to walk out in England Wales Northern
Ireland on Thursday they're demanding a
pay rise of around 17 the union says it
will call off the action if the
government starts negotiating a new wage
deal but the foreign secretary insists
it's not for ministers to haggle over
NHS pay so we put in place an
independent pay review body we've
accepted and implemented their findings
in full of course the health secretary
wants to talk to the profession about
how we can make the about make the job
better how we can improve the NHS
performance for everybody
but could this week be just the start
Junior doctors walked out in 2016 for
the first time in four decades ahead of
a ballot next month their Union is clear
about the pay Rises they want now and
the chances of future strikes
I think it's likely unless the
government is willing to negotiate with
us about pay so we're asking for a
reversal of a pay cut we've had you know
a pay cut for junior doctors of 26.1
since 2008 and so over a quarter of our
pay has been lost
it's been calmer than usual here in
recent weeks but Christmas cheer is
probably still in short supply for a
prime minister being squeezed on several
fronts on the one side Rishi sunak has
striking workers demanding higher pay
and more spending but on the other Tory
MPS are increasingly starting to agitate
around last month's tax Rising Autumn
statement 40 of them have written to the
chancellor expressing concern about how
public money is spent this isn't full-on
Rebellion yet but it could be a
precursor to big battles to come
this former Tory MEP from the right of
the party who's chairing a new campaign
to increase party democracy says there
are many worries about the direction of
the government conservatives thought
well what do we stand for anymore and
what is the difference between us and
the resurgent labor party so I think we
have to get back to core values
um they're not just on the right they
can be right across the party this is
about democracy
um and and reassert those values
politics aside the end result is a week
ahead where most people will notice the
impact of strike action who they blame
for it will shape the political Fallout
and the fortunes of the Prime Minister
Rob Powell Sky News in Westminster